let's go next to trey from
missouri trey you're on the air can you
hear me
yes i can so i've been kind of studying
um voter suppression and i've kind of
wanted to
kind of drill down just briefly like do
republicans vote suppress
because they understand that if more
people vote
we tend to lose and why hasn't congress
enacted on this
so there's a couple different questions
there yet republicans have admitted many
times
that the ways in which they suppress the
vote
they believe are good for them uh you
can go back to the mike turzai video
from 2011 or 2012 where he says voter id
will deliver mitt romney
we'll deliver pennsylvania to mitt
romney in the 2012 election
you can go to the 2020 campaign with
trump saying you know if democrats are
able to do all this stuff and getting
all these people voting will never win
again like they seem to know that in
general
it being easier to vote is not
particularly good for them
in terms of why congress hasn't done
more this is a really great question
and one of the things i called for
earlier this week when we reported on
the 253 voter suppression bills that
republicans are pushing
across the country right now is that if
you have the house the senate and the
white house the way democrats do now
if you can't get something more
permanent done at the federal level on
voting right now
then arguably you you can never do it
of course the reality is much more
complicated and you have to
understand that there are limitations to
you know states do run their own
elections
and so when you had the voting rights
act and the supreme court said okay
we're going to undo this
but this list of states needs to check
with us if they want to change laws
because they have a history of racially
based voter suppression
that's a rare sort of federal oversight
over how states run elections but for
the most part
states get to decide as long as it's not
straight up illegal or unconstitutional
which means you have to take each
decision to court one by one
it's basically a mess is the reason why
we can't just have the federal
government say
we're doing away with all of these voter
suppression tactics
all right i'm from missouri so i've been
keeping an eye on our legislature and
our legislature's
you know been passing bills aimed at
making it harder to vote as a black man
you know i i fear that you know that's
directly targeted at me and so
i just wanted to i just wanted to ask
you and see you know what are your
thoughts on that and why
you know congress hasn't enacted and i
understand that you know with
people like joe manchin and kirsten
cinema making it hard for us to do
anything
uh to get stuff like the john lewis
voting rights act done
i just was curious to hear your thoughts
but yeah i think it's more
complicated than just joe manchin may
not may not go for it i actually think
that there's real
there there are legitimate issues about
federal supremacy when it comes to
election law
and um i i think it's a little more
complicated than that but i'm right with
you
in that right now democrats have the
white house house and senate
if they can't do something about this
issue now legislatively
arguably they never can or or they never
will
all right thanks for the call man my
pleasure thank you for calling
there is trey from missouri one of our
sponsors is vincero
watches giving you 15 off a high quality
wristwatch
is the perfect way to elevate your style
own at least
one watch that makes you feel great when
you put it on
you can often see me wearing my ventura
watch on the show
mine is the gunmetal vessel model i'm a
big fan of the metallic look
of the face of the watch i like the
silicone strap
you won't find a better made watch for
this good a price
anywhere else when you put it on you
know you got more than you paid for
vincero believes in crafting super
quality watches from high-end materials
but selling them at fair prices which is
why they have over twenty six thousand
five star reviews and they stand behind
every watch they make with a one-year
return policy and
five year warranty they'll give you 15
percent off everything in their store
and free shipping
at davidpakman.com watch use the coupon
code
pacman